look when you get the world economic
forum you know some of their some of the
individuals involved with them
advocating for
western intervention in ukraine which
many people fear could trigger a nuclear
conflict or a greater conflict you're
like
these great reset people sure do want a
war maybe not all of them i don't know
but enough of them and that's kind of
scary
you know so you're going to get a lot
more people who are going to believe
these kinds of conspiracies or who are
going to believe their some nefarious
agenda and then then i'll put it this
way
if you go to
any right actually i'll i'll start this
way there's a meme it says please do not
feed the animals because they'll become
dependent
and you know so the meme then shows that
says what's the difference between this
and social programs if you go to a human
talking about deer population
someone who knows likes who lives out in
a rural area and asks them what happens
when the deer population grows too large
they'll say oh it's a disaster they
disease starts spreading they start
decimating local you know plant
populations you get an imbalanced
ecosystem so hunters need to go out and
actually start culling the herd
then asks
somebody what happens if there's too
many people on the planet and they'll
say
i don't know well i don't know so this
idea that humans are comparable to deers
here i would or deer here i would reject
because as the world population has
increased overall poverty globally has
decreased people that's actually my
point no yeah yeah no exactly people are
more capable of providing for themselves
in finding creative solutions to
scarcity than any animal is well the
issue with uh
with it's not just deer but any large
population hogs for instance it's not
just decimating the environment which i
think humans do to a certain degree it's
also just the spread of disease and then
you also have the uh was it the rat
utopia experiment where you end up with
um what was it called cultures beautiful
ones yeah but it was it was like it
wasn't called culture moral sync is what
it's called uh uh uh behavioral systems
yeah behavioral sync is one of the
things that occurs are you familiar with
that never heard of it so there was the
the rat utopia experiment put a bunch of
rats and or mice like not and or rats or
mice different experiments into a space
with tons of food and water and they
could never had to worry about food or
water
and what happened was once they reached
a certain population size they started
behaving in ridiculous ways they started
fighting each other some only groomed
themselves they
like just basically their behaviors are
degraded to the point where they wiped
themselves out
and some of the the mice or rats that
were in the experiment were taken out
and rescued and placed in regular
populations but retained the bad
behaviors that ultimately like destroyed
the previous rat utopia
so there's two ways to look at it
if we are overpopulated i'm saying if we
are some people think we're not
if we are
then we're going to end up with mass
pollution we're going to end up with
serious disease pover not necessarily
poverty but you know issues that will
result in a collapse if we are not
overpopulated
but um we are over abundant in over
abundance there's it's like either we go
the ret utopia route where all of a
sudden we have behavioral sync we
destroy ourselves morally ethically and
functionally and then cease to exist
or we overpopulate we destroy our
environment and then choke ourselves to
death
on our own farts
hmm maybe that's a very pessimistic way
of looking at things that's a little
dark i think but i'm referring
specifically just i'm not saying those
are true to happen i'm just saying in
reference to the fact there's a major
war breaking out that there's great
reset people who are advocating for
expanding the war i'm just making these
points
maybe that's their view or something i
don't think necessarily the world is
overpopulated uh i think the problem
comes when if if it is overpopulated and
people also don't have a goal or
something to actually do which is why
whenever i see this push for like a
government dependency and people just
needing the government to protect them
and save them and do everything for them
that's when i get worried because i'm
like okay you're not actually doing
anything to
keep yourself you know you know what i'm
trying to say like that's i think you
make a really good point which i'll uh
add on to i don't think we're in the ret
utopia yet the rat utopia will happen
the moment all of us agree the
government should do everything for us
because then you end up with the rats
sitting around where the food and water
was given to them right so long as the
rest of us are striving and have purpose
and drive we're resistant to that
behavioral sync and also the ability to
spread out because the utility
experiment was all about being in an
enclosed space so if we can get off
earth where i think it's a big
yes getting off earth but in the right
utopia when there was space they would
still all go only in one side and
densely pack it's like cities that's
like the idea
we could spread out but we don't because
everyone wants to be by everyone else
i was going to say i think my conclusion
this far based on all the chaos we've
seen is that i don't think that people
can live properly in cities that's been
my conclusion i'm like i don't think
that's healthy for people maybe that's
based on our talk about the rat utopia
experiments but people aren't meant to
live that close together yeah i went to
new york once it was terrible yeah
i want to add i want to add i lived
there once
i want to add a caveat i think i hear
what you're saying but i would argue
that people are not meant to live that
close to each other without
accountability so historically people
lived in tribes where in many cases you
were really right on top of one another
right but people knew your face and they
knew your name so if you got out of line
that was going to be corrected very
quickly in cities you're very close to
other people but there there's this
strange anonymity there
i like to think of it this way
when uh it's like it's like the various
states of matter when you live out in a
rural area you you are in like a gaseous
community that means you as an
individual can bounce around and do
crazy stuff freely moving around as you
move into more suburban areas the amount
you can move is less so you're acting
more like a liquid and then when you
live in cities you're all stacked on top
of each other hard compressed and you're
stuck exactly where you're what i mean
by this is
you we have a sphere of freedom and the
more the closer you get to someone else
the more you're compressing that sphere
so for example in new york they pass
crazy laws like you can't own guns you
can't have ammo and you can't play drums
in your house for instance why because
the noise would bother somebody and they
would fight and they're like no no you
can't play loud music out here in the
middle of nowhere you can shoot guns
yeah like you could not only can you
have the guns you can shoot them and be
very very noisy and nobody cares because
you have more space that could also
explain why formation psychosis tends to
appear in with what you consider the
liberal environment in the cities
because when you're so densely packed
information passes through you like a
like a
like atomically in a solid you can fire
current through it much faster than
through a gas because it's it's just got
something to move right not getting
bounced off that's a really good point
basically
if you've got 10 people all smashed next
to each other and then you tap one on
the shoulder and say you know carrots
are healthy the information travels
rapidly down the line because everyone
can conveys it to the other person yeah
whereas i mean we don't even need to use
the physics analogy if you live in a
rural area and someone comes knocks on
your door and says carrots are good for
you you have to get in your car and go
drive to your neighbor's house and let
them know and that's very difficult
relative to yelling out the window hey
jim what carrots are good for you all
right
that's it right no no it's true i mean
yeah ideas uh travel and evolve more
quickly in a more densely populated
environment for better or for worse
because that's true for good i think for
work for bad ideas yeah i think
generally for worse because even if you
start with a good idea it can be warped
and twisted into something else and to
be fair i think you could argue that a
bad idea could sort of be twisted into
something better but it's for worse
because bad ideas travel really really
fast and need to be checked and when
something's traveling slowly you have
you have an opportunity for the truth to
shut it down and then catch it as it's
spreading when you're in a city you have
a bad idea it just ripples right through
travels halfway around the world before
the truth can strap on its boots same in
crowds if someone panics in a crowd the
entire crowd starts to move with that
panic that's that's similar to being in
a city and for war i just watched the
sum of all fears do you guys ever see
that movie
no oh man you guys can't see it it's
good when's it from ben affleck i don't
know 2004 or something ben affleck
morgan freeman uh some other people and
basically what happens is
there's like some organization is trying
to trigger nuclear war between russia
and the us
and so a bomb goes off
in in baltimore and the us is like it
had to have been russia russia's like it
wasn't us but the us doesn't believe us
and then so the russian president is
like keep our defenses on high alert
then the the president of the u.s goes
you know our advisor says mr president
russia has just put all their defenses
on high alert and he's like what and
he's like get our fleets ready because
he sees them reacting and then they both
start escalating to the point but then i
guess you know like something happens i
don't want to spoil the movie well i
guess it's from 2004 so i'm going to
split up no hold on let me take my
headphones off so basically
ben affleck intervenes and gets a
message sent to the russian president
saying you're being played by terrorists
i know you didn't fire that you didn't
detonate that nuke in baltimore
stand down it's the only way and then
russia agrees and stands down all
weapons and then the u.s says stand down
stand out but they were doing a
countdown for a missile strike or
whatever basically my point is when one
side gets scared and the information is
rapid then it's just
escalation so there was like there was a
story i heard once where like two guys
got into a minor fender bender but one
guy was like road raging and really
angry and when he gets out they're both
armed and the guy's all super angry and
he's like hey you hit me you rear-ended
me and the guy who regretted him was an
accident sees that he's got a gun so he
puts his hand on his hip and says back
up buddy the other guy sees him reaching
for his gun so he grabs his gun the
other guy see him he's grabbed his gun
and pulls his gun and then the other guy
pulls his gun and then someone gets shot
yep because they both you know we're in
this heated moment they're like no don't
do it stop no then they both pull their
weapons out so things like that can
happen you know i hope that's not where
we're going with this russia stuff but
the issue i suppose is that
no one's gonna back down
no one will like why would anyone back
down you know it's it's it's
i i actually you know i think maybe the
west backs down in this one because
we're the morally weaker like uh maybe
not morally here's the right word we're
the ideologically weaker faction here
well didn't russia offer terms to
ukraine today yep okay yeah ukraine was
like nope really yeah they said eastern
region the donbass region and crimea are
now russia can't join nato you can't
join nato or any bloc like the eu or
anything like that it kind of sounds
like ukraine is just gunning for
eu
nato membership at this point it seems
like they're using this conflict to push
towards being joined with those groups i
don't know that's just my observation
i'm not the foreign policy expert but
they are being incredibly stubborn i
don't know thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you